hey welcome back to our channel my name
is samuel and i'm amanda and this is the
samuel and amanda show
and today we're going to be talking
about we're going to be talking about
all the different strategies that they
are in property
and i'm going to be given my take on
what i think about them yeah because you
you hear me talk about all the different
strategies all the time like lease
option agreements rent to rents
biorefurbishing finance service
accommodation deal sourcing and
you might hear my perspective on these
different strategies but i wanted amanda
to glean
in her perspective what we think the
best strategies are
i mean i don't we've not even prepared
this so we might disagree
and start arguing live on the podcast um
but please do us a massive favor though
if you enjoy our channel
hit the like button subscribe why should
they subscribe and hit the like button
because we give lots and lots of good
content
every single day on this channel and you
don't want to miss an
update so hit like subscribe turn the
notification bell on
but first how is your week going what
have you been up to
my week's going really well so i've
joined you on the property millionaire
intensive tour
and um so that's been really really cool
and today is the last day of the tour
but also today is a really special day
for us because
it's our wedding anniversary this is our
wedding anniversary
six years six years married today
although technically six and a half
because we did the african
yes zimbabwe money marriage ebola um
six months prior yeah we are in a hotel
room
we do have a six-month-old baby behind
us
who is awake so we i don't know how this
is going to go
if we can see one take it will be
amazing hey jessica
isn't she awesome so okay cool
anniversary
we've been on tour let's hit let's get
right to with the strategies uh i want
to get your take on it so first strategy
is
and when when we met yeah i was doing
this
aggressively and that is deal sourcing
packaging deals and passing them onto
investors
one of the best strategies one of my
favorite strategies
what do you think about deal sourcing i
think it's a really good strategy
go on what you're fat you say your face
when you said you think it's really good
strategy it's like there's a butt coming
yeah there is a butt there is a book
coming i know you i know you love it
samuel
you love it and you're very good at it
but i must say for me
personally i can't hear this i think
that it's quite a
high pressure like thing to do
like you know finding deals making sure
they're really really good
obviously yes you do due diligence to
make sure that they're right for the
investor yeah
but i think that it's a lot of weight to
have and then not only do you have that
but then also having to
speak to the investors and sell to them
and close them on the phone
without seeing the property i think it
takes a lot of skills to do that and
i'm just like oh my gosh i've heard you
speaking with people on the phone in the
past and i'm just like
oh my goodness what are you like oh my
goodness why are you like that
because sometimes the deal might fall
through for whatever reason then you've
got the refund process
yeah yeah yeah or you've just got
sometimes investors that are just
really really difficult to please and
mandate
mandate okay buying a house yeah
stop is stressful yes you're taking away
the stress for the investors so yeah of
course you're taking on a bit of stress
a bit right yeah you're taking a little
bit yeah before that
you're not putting out any money yep
you're
you can start pretty much from scratch
and you're you're taking on a bit of
stress for the investor
you're getting paid like three four
thousand pounds to do that
yeah and it's a lot of money to get paid
for something that
i just think that sometimes the investor
when they do then see the property or
sometimes just people that might be a
bit difficult to deal with and they have
to have these really hard conversations
with them
it does take skills it does it takes a
great skill i think oh i'll be able to
sell it it does but
yeah if you can package and sell one
deal a week
which is very very part-time you're
gonna be making 12
grand a month which is way more than the
average salary yeah
so you can't expect it to be old i don't
want any pressure
i want no pressure i don't want to have
to buy the house myself i don't have any
money but i want to get paid really well
yeah there is some pressure yeah
yeah but all right this is no question
girl
what's your what's your what's your
what's one of your favorite strategies
one of my favorites is the brr by
refurbished refinance strategy
i love that yeah but that's can i just
say that don't just say it i have to
argue with you now go on
that's way more stressful than packaging
and selling a deal i don't know
i feel like it's easier because in my
experience
when you're looking after the project
and then say if you've got a client
you're doing it for someone
i think it's just easy to manage their
expectations so it's easy to just be
ahead of the game and then tell the
investor like oh
this is what's happening oh we're a bit
behind i just feel like it's a bit
for me it's easier for me i feel like
i'm more comfortable
that's like my you know what i think we
deal selling sorry i'm really hung up
you find a good deal you find an
investor you sell it to them
then you say look now have a look at it
and if you're happy with it
like but then your job is kind of done
with your brr
it's like a six to twelve it's like a
six to 12 month process
yeah i mean i do like brr you're a
conscious about that
and yeah i love like being on site
looking at the house watching it
transport i love that sort of stuff so
for me
yeah it doesn't feel like you know it's
stressful or
what i think one of the things that is
stressful about brr go on what about
the cost of materials over the last 12
months oh my gosh yeah because of covid
and stuff i think
yeah that is really really bad so the
delays the bill to say no we haven't got
this in so then
your project's been delayed that's been
quite going up
how
yeah um like even jessica's going crazy
about it she's outraged she's outraged
i mean and if you're doing a brr deal my
advice would be to make sure that the
figures really stack
sometimes people because they love doing
it you know
they might want to go for a property
that doesn't quite stack up just because
they like the house
oh i can just imagine visualizing myself
but it's like that stuff's fun
but make sure the form of the stack make
sure the biggest stat because if you're
off just by 10
on the refurb and then just 10 on the
end value
nearly all of your profits gone so make
sure there's enough cushion in the
profit
uh what's your favorite part of bar
refurbishment finance you've obviously
got the buying process you've got the
refurbishing you've got the refinancing
they're putting the tenants in at the
end
like what's your favorite part i just
love the end when you can then
dress the house and make it look pretty
and then obviously showing the value
around
showing them like this is my baby this
is what i've done that's really fun okay
lease option agreements
lease option agreements are really
really good we use them all the time
don't we on
our development deals i i use them to
get started
um so describe in your words because
they've heard it from me before
what is a lease option agreement lease
option agreement is basically like
buy now pay later so you get the
property you take hold
you take control of it you pay the
mortgage payments you get the tenants in
the person that owns it is basically
just you're the new owner effectively
not on paper
and then you then agree to buy it in say
five to ten years time
the value of the property's probably
gone up so you're getting it for a
bargain price
and you'll benefit from the rent every
month yeah you can do it on land
where you can get an option to buy a
piece of land but then you can add value
by getting planning permission
uh but then if you can't get planning
permission you walk away so
options we we both love yeah we can
agree that we both love you
yeah yeah yeah okay what about
serviced accommodation surface
accommodation is great
especially right now like with the
staycations
they were cool before but i think now
it's even more like a prime time to get
into it and do it
and you love that like that finishing
touch job don't you
oh this looks amazing yeah yeah i think
with service accommodation
i love service accommodation and i think
right now it's absolutely popping and
the thing is it's so tax efficient as
well like the capital allowances if
you're buying a property to do service
accommodation
you can get reduced stamp duty you've
got the
um if you systemize it right you've got
the really high cash flow that you're
going to get from it
but when you refurb a property and then
do a service accommodation i think
that's probably
the best feeling because it's like a
really mucky property push the value up
refurb the house then kick it out really
nice it's just like you've turned
yeah derelict run down property you've
had no stamp duty on the property
because it's not even habitable
and then now it's this beautiful hotel
effect that everyone wants to stay in
yeah
yeah so service guy and service
accommodation is one of the most popular
strategies with our students as well
oh man so many of our students um pop in
with service accommodation
um joint ventures joint ventures great
as well
really really good for someone that you
know when you can find someone if you've
got lots
lots of time and then you find someone
that's got lots of money but not the
time and then you know it's like a
perfect match
yeah then you can join adventures so i
think that's really cool if you haven't
got any money
you've got the knowledge then you can
collaborate with someone who
you know can give you the money so one
of the things that we're going to be
teaching today
um at this program in warsaw we're in
warsaw by the way where
this hotel was where i did my very very
first crash course so it's really cool
being back here
but one of the things we're going to be
teaching today is hmos and the great
thing about places like warsaw where we
are right now
is warsaw has not got any article four
which means you have permitted
development rights
so you can buy a house and you can just
turn it into a hmo
without getting planning but then when
they bring in article 4 which they will
soon
then that property will have automatic
grandfather rights which means the value
will go up we saw this happen in
wolverhampton
we saw it happen in birmingham now we're
in warsaw so i love hmos
you've had the brunt of managing a lot
of my channels yeah
i'm like no thanks no thanks i think
it's really cool when you're starting
out
i think it's really good skill to learn
how to deal with tenants that sort of
thing but
oh my goodness it's a lot of work but we
we we've got a lot of htmls now but we
just
we've just either got really good
management families in place or we've
passed it on to corporate let's or
social housing
still hmos but it's just that you used
to
literally how many rooms did you manage
at one time our own
120. yeah i was going to say 120. 120
oh my goodness yeah it was a lot but
it's i think they're really really good
for cash flow
hms if you're married if you're managing
more than
four or five hmos it will become a bit
of a job
it will become a bit of a job so again
make sure when you take on hmos that you
just systemize them you get good hm
management companies
top tip for top tier for getting good hm
management companies in place
i probably say just go on spare room and
then look at the ads there's lots and
lots of uh managers on there and usually
you can see when they've rented out it
will say they'll have a strike through
all the rooms you see the ones that i
like that you know that they're very
good at renting out their room so get in
touch with them and speak with them
although something interesting is a lot
of our properties to be fair
we'd rent the rooms out but we wouldn't
say it's rented out because
you want an ever flowing call of
potential tenants
uh but yeah that's great also referrals
ask around
go into if you're going into a new area
to hms find someone else that's doing
hmos ask them
if you can pick their brain share
resources yeah
uh get trained i always say this but
when you step back into new strategies
make sure you've got the education
so which brings us to we're gonna
obviously crack on i'm gonna go
downstairs i've got 250 people waiting
for me downstairs
i got a wonderful wife who's it's my
anniversary of so this is going to be a
little bit of a shorter one than normal
so amanda final words of wisdom
okay so they are feel the fear and do it
anyway so
all of these strategies that can seem a
bit daunting and
really scary but i think when you're
equipped with the right training
and you know exactly what you're
supposed to be doing you might feel a
bit scared to step out and do it but
just
feel feel the fear and just go for it
anyway yeah i love it
taking action is ultimately the key to
success so
good luck guys go smash it if you need
any help let me know
hit me up on instagram subscribe and we
will see you
next time see ya